de fotógrafo a activista ambiental sus
aires sacar ya paso de capturar
fotografías de la naturaleza de malasia
a conservarlas y
una de las razones por las que ayuda a
salvar las especies de orquídeas en las
áreas madereras es porque cuando voy
allí encuentro que muchas especies de
orquídeas o plantas se están
extinguiendo sentí que sería un
desperdicio si dejábamos que continuara
así que pensé que lo mejor para
salvarlas era traerlas de vuelta y
replantar las en casa
la fauna del país está en peligro más de
500 especies de plantas en la península
de malasia han sido clasificadas como
amenazadas
ante el peligro sacaría convirtió su
patio en un conservatorio en
europa vivimos en esta tierra y no
tenemos ningún otro planeta que pueda
sustentar a la humanidad como este
entonces si los humanos destruyen su
propia tierra indirectamente están
creando su propio infierno
a través de su proyecto autofinanciado
ha ayudado a salvar dos mil plantas de
las que 200 son orquídeas sus preferidas
un trabajo en el que también ayuda a
investigadores y entusiastas a
identificar gran cantidad de plantas
entera para ti
entonces es autodidacta en el sentido de
que aprendió todo por sí mismo tiene un
talento raro donde puede difundir su
conocimiento científico a la gente va
juan sainz science and real de youtube
capaz de marcar las selvas tropicales
caracterizan el paisaje malasio son uno
de sus grandes atractivos y de las
razones de su riqueza ambiental pero
casi el 30% se ha perdido por la
deforestación desde 2001